le prix des maisons at-il réellement
grimpé de 300 mille dollars en cinq ans
au canada
oui c'est vrai le prix moyen d'une
propriété tous titres confondus est
passé de 430 4000 $ en novembre 2015 à
736 mille dollars en juillet dernier
selon l' indice des prix mls la hausse
dépasse donc un publi 300 mille dollars
on a reculé jusqu'en 2006 quand les
conservateurs de stephen harper ont
formé le gouvernement pour voir comment
les prix ont évolué on le voit sur le
graphique
il ya eu une accélération importante à
compter de 2016 il y en a eu une autre
avec la pandémie les prix sont encore
plus élevés à vancouver et à toronto
alors que montréal arrive sous la
moyenne canadienne
pourquoi les prix ont grimpé aussi
rapidement parce que le déséquilibre
entre l'offre et la demande s'est
accentuée
selon un rapport de la banque scotia la
croissance de la population a été plus
importante dans les cinq dernières
années notamment en raison de
l'immigration
au canada il y à 424 unités de logement
pour chaque millier de personnes si plus
faible que dans tous les autres pays du
g7 qui en comptent en moyenne 4 171 pour
en arriver là il faudrait construire un
million huit cent mille maisons
selon nous c'est d'ailleurs de tous les
pays du g7 c'est au canada que le prix
des maisons a grimpé le plus rapidement
depuis 2006